تتوقع أن تجد Cheetos في وعاء
أو كيس ليس في حقل ، نعم هناك
تمثال حتى أن تميمة الوجبات الخفيفة
قد تسميها
جبنيًا بشكل خطير ، ستفاجأ
بعدد الأشخاص الذين يريدون الاقتراب
والشخصية مع Cheeto العملاق في  في
أي لحظة ، ربما حصلنا على ما يقرب من 40 إلى
50 شخصًا هنا حتى الآن أي ما يقرب من
نصف سكان تشيتو ألبرتا بكندا ،
قام صانعو Cheetos بتكليف
منحوتة بطول 17 قدمًا صنعتها
شركة محلية تصنع الدعائم السينمائية ، وكان
مجلس إدارة Cheetos سعيدًا بذلك.
احصل عليه هنا وأعني أنه يضعك يا
رفاق على الخريطة بشكل صحيح ، لا
تحصل هاملت على أي شيء من هذا
بخلاف الكثير من السياح الذين يتجولون في
مدينتنا معظمهم يلتقطون صورًا ذاتية ،
إنها الصفقة الحقيقية التي غالبًا ما يتم
طرحها مع Cheetos في متناول اليد  على الرغم من أن هذا الرجل اختار الظهور
في مسابقة Behind Enemy
Lines كما قال ، فقد اختار صانعو Cheetos
Cheeto لأن Cheeto يبدو مثل
Cheeto وهو اسمهم
للغبار البرتقالي الذي ينتهي بك الأمر إلى ذلك.
امسح يديك أو ألعق أصابعك ،
لذلك أراد الكثير من الناس التعامل مع
Cheeto ، وسرعان ما ارتفعت علامة ، يرجى
عدم تسلق السياج أو تمثال يد
Cheetos هنا فقط حتى أوائل
نوفمبر ، كيس من Cheetos لن يدوم طويلاً
حتى  ثم يأكله السائحون كما
لو كنا
جيدًا ، من المحتمل أن يأكل هذا السائح
أي شيء وقد خدع هذا الرجل
صورة سيلفي Cheeto ليجعل الأمر يبدو وكأنه كان
يعض أكثر مما يمكنه أن يمضغ
جمهورًا حقيقيًا Genie Mouse CNN New
York